[Music]
who is my girl my girl has love in her
heart and snow in her eyes in her life
every birthday kiddo mrs. Norris I'm
very sorry for your loss we have three
suspects in custody but they're all
linked to the Garcia cartel no witnesses
have been willing to step up these
cartels are no joke they've got everyone
net pockets you've been through a
terrible tragedy maybe you didn't see
what you think you saw did maybe you've
made a mistake number three number five
Number Four your recollection isn't what
you thought it was the evidence is
insufficient to hold the defendants over
for trial you think that you're gonna
have justice make them all all day
five years ago Crowley North disappeared
completely off the grid so she spends
the last five years doing what training
well that's new he honestly think Riley
North did this
today's the five year anniversary of her
family's murder she's back
we have judges dirty cops
not a coincidence that makes this area
low crime it is no crime because of her
me somebody's doing something find her I
don't care if you have to burn this city
down watching someone take everything
from you it turns you into somebody else
social media is lit up with support for
she's a multiple homicide suspect not to
them she's not man and now God
[Music]
I will kill every one of you now that
I'm pretty much wing it from there
[Music]
you